the pan psychist story is what's at the
fundamental level
uh
networks of incredibly simple
conscious entities behaving in very
simple predictable ways because they
have very simple Consciousness through
their interactions
realizing certain mathematical
structures and patterns
and then the thought is
those mathematical structures and
patterns are what we call physics so we
get physics out of underlying facts
about Consciousness absolutely beautiful
all right you can't get Consciousness
out of physical out of physical matter
but you can get physical matter out of
Consciousness we know it can be done so
that is why this is such an attractive
theoretical story so the thesis is that
matter is composed of the the base
elements of Consciousness somehow
somewhere yeah